مرحبا
[تصفيق]
طيب
بلحظه هيك مجنونه
قررت فجاه اني انفصل عن اهلي
قررت واجه الحياه بكل تفاصيلها لحالي
طبعا بعض الصراعات وجدالات مع اهلي
اقتنعوا لكن بشرط بسبب حساسيه المرحله
العمريه يعني 18 سنه 19 سنه
بشوط كان هو زياده تفقديه وفينا نقول
كبسات
لما عشت لحالي
تعلمت اجلي تعلمت اطبخ امسح صلح صحيه صلح
كهرباء يعني صرت ست بيت ممتازه
كل الاحوال يعني كانت تواجهني اوقات
صعوبات
بوحدتي باصدقاء بجيران لحتى اتغلب عليها
كمان كانت تصير معي مواقف تلبك خاف
بتذكر المره كان الدنيا مثل هالايام برد
وكمان ما في مازوت كانت الدنيا شت ومثل
العاده مقطوعه الكهرباء يعني تقريبا حوالي
12 بالليل قاعد بالتخت دفيان
فجاه
بسمع صوت مثل هذا الباب
انا ما بتذكر حالي اني اليوم طلعت على
البرنده
المهم قوم يعني
فتحت الباب تماما نفس هذا الصوت
بعد صراع شديد انا والحاف والحرام قمت
وشديت حالي هيك لباب الباندا بس بتفاجا
انه الباب مسكر
سحبت حالي ورجعتها اختي تغطيت غطيت راسي
حطيت سماعات باذنيه شغلت موسيقى ونمت
هلا كيف نمت ما بعرف بس نمت
تاني يوم بالشغل قلت له لو في انه تلفزيون
عندي منزوع تطلع تساوي طبعا هي كانت كذبه
مشان اذا في شيء بالبيت يخبرني يعني انا
ماني عرفان شو هو
فعلا طلع معي على البيت قعدنا وساوا لي
التلفزيون والى اخره اللي هو ما كان فيه
شيء اصلا يسالني شو بقولو ما بعرف
المهم حمل حاله الزلمه وراح
قعدت انا
بسمع صوت كعب
كانه سيده عم تفتل حواليا بدي الا اذا
حلوه بيني استحيت
كم يوم عن البيت
ورجعت
بتذكر اني سكرت باب البيت وقفلته من جوا
وخليت المفتاح
فتحت على المطبخ لحط الاغراض
البيت انفتح
وتسكر
شو بدي اعمل قلت رح اعمل شيء معاكس للمنطق
بدي واجه الصوت بصوت
كل ما سمعت صوت بدي اعلي صوت الموسيقى
هيك
ومش طبيعي
نمت تاني يوم بدي انزل على شغلي ساويت
نسكافيه شغلت فيروز كمان بسمع بابي بعندهم
فتح وتسكر فورا بحركه واحده كنت معلي صوت
المسجله على الاخر
ما بحس الا باب البيت عم ينخبط خبط دش
قوم افتح ولا لا اقعد يعني قوم لافتح هيك
شد حالي امشي اخر شي فتحت لسه ما فتحت
الباب تطلع لي وحده بتقول لي وبعدين معك
سرعتني بالموسيقى شو الله بلاني وحياتي
على حيطك اسبوع ساكنه بهالبيت
عليها الباب
هاي الاصوات كلها حيطه على حياتك عم تطلع
من عندك صار لي اسبوع
[تصفيق]
لكن قال لا تاخذ صاحب الا من بعد قتله
فالمخلوقه صارت تفقدني دائما سكبه من هون
سكبه من هون يوم يبرق يوم كوسا يوم كذا
اذا طالع الدبش
[تصفيق]
بس السؤال انه كيف جابتي ولا يوم انتبهت
علي وانا ماشي بهاي
معقول شافتها وما عرفت شو هي انا ساكن انا
وجابا بطابق واحد
بنايه وحده اسبوع ولا اليوم شافتني
تنفض شافتني ما سالت حالها شو هاي ما
خطتها علي الباب وتقول لي نحن جيرانك سكنا
طيبكم انا ليش ماسك
على فكره
اغلب الاغاني اللي انا حافظها عن ظهر قلب
ولا يمكن اني امشي فيها واتعثر
بس المشكله اللي ممكن اتعسب بفجوه كبيره
بين الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه
ولاسيما الاعاقه البصريه
والمجتمع هاي الفجوه بتكمل وين
انه المجتمع بطيبته واخلاقه بحب كتير يمد
ايد العون للاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه وبحب
يساعدهم
لكن تكمل الفجوه بعدم معرفتهم وقله خبرتهم
بطريقه المساعده يعني مثلا ممكن انا هلا
اكون ماشي بالطريق
وفجاه قبل شوي من السيارات فبيجي واحد
البعيد بيقول لي يمينك يساعدك
هلا الاشكاليه كمان وين انه يكون شخص
يمينه
او كون ماشي بشوارع الشام واسال حدا بدلني
غلط
الفجوه هاي بين قله الخبره والعاطفه
الزائده
الاشخاص المكفوفين دائما بتدون
يعني نعرف نحن شو الطريقه اللي بتناسبون
مثلا الحل هون شو بيكون بدل ما يصلي من
بعيد ويلخبط لانه هذا شو يمكن يؤدي لاذى
ممكن يقرب من هذا الشخص ويساله انت شو
اللي بدك اياه كيف ممكن اساعدك قد تكون عم
قرب انا من السيارات في باص معين او
ميكروب سمعت صوت ميكروفون بيوقف اساله
واطلع فيه ممكن يكون سمعت صوت شخص وبدي
اساله عنوان ممكن فعلا كنت تايه يعني كتير
ناس بتقول لي خليك ماشي دغري ليش انت
بتعرف هذا المكان
طيب
هذا الشي بيعمل تشويش بيعمل لببكه على
مبدا صوت كعب الكندره صوت كعب الكندره انا
بسمعه دائما بالمجتمع لكن بطرق مختلفه
مشان هيك
بدنا نعرف كيف نوجه هاي الاشخاص ونساعدها
طيب هلا بدي منكم شغله انه ناخذ نفس طويل
ونغمض عيوننا
وتفكروا معي ليش انا هون
ليش
بعمله 18 سنه تعرضت لحادث سير ادى فقدان
بصري تدريجيا
فجاه بوعوا على حالي فاقد للبصل تماما
بعد ما وعيت وبلشت بدي افكر
قلت كيف بدي اقاوم رغبتي لرؤيه الاشياء
كيف بدي اتذكر الطبقات اللي كنت امشي فيها
قديش بدي اشتاق لاني اشوف الوجوه اللي
بحبها
طبعا صدمه كبيره
اهلي حطوني قدام الصوره الحقيقيه قدام
الواقع والمجتمع والخيارات بس المشكله انه
انا ما كان عندي اي دافع لاني اعمل شي
كنت بالثانوي يعني بكالوريا اهلي اول خطوه
عملوها انه تواصلوا مع اصدقائي مع المدرسه
مع اسادستي انه يحافظوا طبعا بالخفاء انا
ما بعرف بعدين عرفت انه يحافظوا على
علاقتهم الطبيعيه معي
وفعلا ما كنت احس بشي هيك لاخذت
البكالوريا حتى بتذكر انه نعرض على والدي
انه ينقلني على مدرسه خاصه بالمكفوفين لكن
والدي يرفض وكانت فكره ذكيه منه بحكم ظرفي
انا انه انا سته شهور وعندي امتحان فتغيير
هذا الواقع ممكن يؤدي لفشل
بعد ما اخدت البكالوريا سجلت بكليه الحقوق
هون كان في فتره استراحه
فالوالده بلشت تبحث عن الاماكن اللي فيها
دورات تاهيليه وتدريبيه للاشخاص المكفوفين
عرفنا هذا الحكي بال 2005 انه في دوله
خاصه بتعليم الكمبيوتر للاشخاص المكفوفين
بطريقه جديده في قارئ او ناطق عربي بيقرا
الشاشه فبمكن الشخص الكفيف من استخدام
الكمبيوتر
هلا انا هون بدي التقي بناس ما بعرفها
بدي اتعرف على ناس من صوتهم من اسلوب
كلامهم من مصافحتهم ممكن اتخيل شكل جسدهم
كمان هاي الناس هلا هي صار لها ممكن تكون
كفيفه من ولادتها او من سنين طويله يمكن
هن يعرفوني اكتر ما انا اعرفهم اتعلم منهم
ادواتهم اسلوبهم
كيف ممكن يتعرفوا على الاشياء وفعلا تم
الموضوع
التحقت بالدوله وتعلمت الكمبيوتر وبعد
تامل طويل
اكتشفت انه الاشخاص المكفوفين قادرين
نعيشوا حياتهم بشكل طبيعي لكن
في حال توفرت الادوات
والامكانيات والوسائل طيب
انا محسن عشت حاله البصر ولا بصل
بدي اسالكم انتم
كيف بتشوفوا الشخص الكفيف
هل هو شخص فقط يستمد المساعده
ام شخص قادر على الانتاج
بدايه بدنا نتفق انه شريحه المكفوفين هي
مثل الشريحه بالمجتمع فيها جيد وفيها
السيء فيها المتعلم وغير المتعلم والملتزم
وغير الملتزم والمبدع والمتخاذل
لكن
لكن في حال دعمناه ونمينا له مهاراته
فحينا نعرف كيف
نوصلوا للسبب اللي نوجد فيه هو بالمجتمع
البناء
الانتاج وحمله الرساله
ب
15/5/2014 هاي القصه صارت يعني بتوضح
الشيء اللي بدي اقوله ذات مخرجه مسرحيه
السكن الجامعي يلي بسكنوا الطلاب
الجامعيين لا سيما الجامعيه للمكفوفين
انتقد مجموعه طلاب بحسب رغبتهم
مجموعه من الطلاب المكفوفين عملت منهم
فرقه مسرحيه هي كان هدفها انه تعمل عود
مسيحي ترفيهي تحط بصيبتها الذاتيه انه
عملت مع المكفوفين لكن الصدمه كانت انه
لقيت عندها هدول الاشخاص ثقافه عاليه
وقدره رهيبه على تعبئه فضاء المسرح وعلى
القيام بالادوار المسيحيه بطريقه متقنه
فجاه بتختفي المخرجه
انه الطلاب فكروا انه هي ما عاد بده واذا
بترجع وحامله بايدها نص يعد من اخطر نصوص
المسرحيه طبعا اسمه هيئه محلفين بحسب
التبيي لكن ماخوذ بالنص عالمي اسمه 12 رجل
غاضب بيعالج عبثيه القتل والظلم
ادوا فرقه المكفوفين والمخرجه العمل
المسرحي وعملوا عده عروض كانت ناجحه حصلت
جوائز كثيره وكانت صدمه الجمهور دائما انه
الاشخاص يلي عم يؤدوا العمل اشخاص مكفوفين
لدرجه انه هدول المحلفين القضاه كانوا
دائما قاعدين عم يكتبوا الجمهور على
المسرح بده يقرا شو مكتوب على
اشكاله باجمل الطرق اللي هو الفن المسرحي
المكفوفين بعد التدريب انه يحملوا هاي
الرساله ويوصلوها
اليوم
بعد هذا الحديث بدي اسالك واسالكم جميعا
انت شو دورك
بيبلش دورك لما بتفصل عاطفتك عن حقيقه
الشخص الكفيف انت لا بتعرف امكانياته
لمستوى التعليمي ولا مهاراته مثل ما قلنا
هي الشريحه متباقي شرائح المجتمع
ثاني شيء لازم تامن انه هذا شخص فاعل قادر
انه يطلع منه شي
بعدين لما بامن بهذا الشخص في حال امنت
بدي اتقرب منه واساله واعرف كيف ممكن
السبب نجاحكم انا اعرف كيف ممكن يوصله
لباب الامان
واليوم لاي شخص كفيف بدي اقول
ما لقى الرعايه او عاطفه اهله الزايده
منعته من الطلعه من البيت والانطلاق
بالحياه انه اولا يتمد
لانه هو اللي بده يبني حياته هو بده يبني
اسرته
واذا كان بيخاف لازم يؤمن انه رب العالمين
من عالي سمع حامي واعي
لازم يدور على مهاراته
ويدور على ادواته
بعد فتره طويله من دراستي للكمبيوتر وصلت
لمرحله
يعني تمكنت اني اعطي كورسات
كمبيوتر للمكفوفين بحيث انه يستخدموا هذا
الجهاز بسوق العمل بتذكر في صبيه بعد ما
دربتها كانت خريجه لغه عربيه اشتغلت
بالاذاعه والتلفزيون وقدمت برنامج
تلفزيوني خاص فيها
كم واحد فيكم بيعرف هذا التاريخ قليل
ممكن يكون كثير بس شو عملنا ما عملنا شي
كمان
درست طريقه لاني تعلمتها عمري 22 سنه اللي
هي القراءه النافره
درسته
ودرستنا مع الكمبيوتر
فوحده من الصبايا اليوم هي انسه بمدرسه
خاصه بالمكفوفين وعم تعلم الطلاب الصغار
بنشوف انه لما هدول المثالين
امنوا بنفسهم ما خجلوا من ادواتهم ووضعهم
يوصلوا للمكانه ممكن يكونوا لقوا فيها
نفسهم فاذا بنرجع بنقول لكل شخص كفيف ما
تخجل من ادواتك تعامل معها هي اللي بتعبر
عنك مثل ما قلنا عن هاي العصايه هاي
العصايه هي اداه
بتعبر عني
هاي الاداه حتفهمك اني انا كفيف اذا ماشي
بالطريق ما تضربني واذا انا ضربتك ما
تلومني لانه مو بقصدي
كل الحادث بدي اختصره بقصه او مثال انا
ومجموعه من اصدقائي المكفوفين
خضعنا لدوله تدريبيه كانت اسعافات اوليه
عن طريق احدى المبادرات الجميله
اهم
فقره بمناوله المسعف هي فقره اسم السي بي
ار
السي بي ار هي عمليه الانعاش يقوم المصحف
بيجس نبض المصاب فما بلاقي نبض هون غالبا
متوقف بيشبك ايديه
وبيحطهم على صدر مصاب ويبلش ينعش هلا في
عنا طرفين المصاب والمسعف قلب المصاب
متوقف قلب مسعف شغال فاذا الطرفين اثنين
عايشين بشو بقلب واحد هدول الطايفين انا
وانت
وشكرا
[تصفيق]